we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p we have not heard from the
louisiana troll for a while but he has
really been activated by the results of
last week's election and i want to hear
from him now you know it sucks back man
of the fact that democrats will never
win another national election and i'm
gonna tell you what ok uh if Trump does
bring back jobs to the rüstov and pretty
much a lot of you know kind of the rural
South America where there are minorities
by the way uh unlike what you think
minorities don't just all live in
inner-city ghettos like you left this
like to uh to claim for some weird
racist reason um they're going to see
four years here's the thing you left it
use minorities as a tool for Democrat
votes that's it and I could prove that
by two different things just look how
nasty you guys are to minorities who
don't vote uh deep I me just turned to
you know Ana Kasparian video which she
unleash on women who were Trump call
them all stupid idiots or look at some
of your videos for you call uh you know
minority still both he Uncle Tom some
other nasties Matthew English met the
Louisiana troll calls in and everything
all this comments are based on things
that have never happened I feel like
he's watching other shows any thinks
it's this show any calls in leaves us
voicemail number one it was Trump
actually who talked about inner cities
interchangeably with talking about
minorities it's Trump who made that
assumption and number two when have we
ever called any Republic person who
doesn't vote for a Democrat and Uncle
Tom we haven't and in fact the data
demonstrates that there is no
justification to the idea that black
voters in 08 in 2012 voted for President
Obama because he was black so Louisiana
troll it's always great to hear from him
I guess not really but I guess it's okay
to hear from him but you've got a call
in about stuff that we've actually said
we've got a great bonus show for you
today please become members you'll get
instant access